india has reported a staggering
400 000 new coronavirus infections in
just
24 hours adding to a week-long streak of
world
record breaking numbers to battle the
devastating second wave
saturday should have marked the start of
a vaccine rollout for hundreds of
millions of over eight teens in india
but most states are not taking part
because there are not
nearly enough vaccines to go around
these are the lucky ones waiting in line
to be vaccinated
and eventually being given their jabs
but plans to begin vaccinating all
adults are in disarray
many states simply don't have any doses
to give out
we are requesting the people of
karnataka especially those who are
above 18 years up to 44 years
to refrain from going to the hospitals
thinking that you may be vaccinated
the company's manufacturing vaccines
will not be able to deliver the doses on
the first of may
so the vaccination drive in madhya
pradesh will not begin
we are completely prepared our
healthcare workers are ready
but we do not have the vaccines
only around 1 in 10 of india's vast
population
has had even a first jab the lack of
doses made worse by
administrative inefficiencies
oxygen and medicines are also in short
supply
pharmacies say there has been panic
buying and hoarding
and they are restricting supplies only
giving out oxygen cylinders to people
who can prove they really need them
emergency care facilities are being set
up
sports halls religious sites and
catering facilities
are being turned into makeshift kovid 19
isolation wards
and the awful task of dealing with the
dead goes on
in the capital delhi volunteers put
themselves at risk
collecting the bodies of those who've
died
two days back i picked up on my own
uncle and he died because we couldn't
supply him oxygen i was working in the
mortuary van
i couldn't pick up the call and the
moment i was able to receive the call he
was already passed away
so it's it's really tough for us
an international relief effort is
underway
to help india fight its devastating
second wave
but deaths and infections are still
rising remorselessly
and with not enough vaccines to go round
for more we're joined now by dw's
nemisia jaiswal hello to you namisha
so india was supposed to expand its
vaccination program today but as we
heard in the report there's simply
not enough vaccine doses to go around
so what will today's rollout look like
well mariana today's rollout is
continuing
but it will in a way highlight india's
systemic issues
of inequality because while the
government has technically allowed
everybody above 18 to be vaccinated
many states including delhi and
maharashtra
two of the worst hit states have said we
do not have enough doses
please do not come out and queue outside
vaccination centers
we will let you know when we have doses
hopefully in a few days
now the indian government has allowed
states to buy directly from
manufacturers
which may well be behind some of these
shortages but in addition
those few people who are getting
vaccinated today
are getting vaccinated at private
hospitals because the government has
also allowed manufacturers
to sell to private hospitals but at a
higher price so those of us getting
vaccinated today are those of us
who can afford to pay for the vaccine
and this once again
will push behind those who cannot afford
it
namisha we do know that india is a major
producer of vaccines and yet it's still
struggling to ramp up vaccine production
for its own population
what is the reason for that
well mariana critics analyze and many
health experts have pointed out that the
indian government
while being aware of the fact that india
is a production hub
may have been too laid back in placing
its orders
some of the most some of the biggest
orders actually only went out in january
and this caused a funding crunch for
these manufacturers
the the serum institute of india the
manufacturer that's rolling out the
oxford vaccine
came out and made a statement saying we
do not have enough funding right now
to ramp up production since then of
course the indian government has
raised orders but they will still need
time to ramp up production
there is also criticism of the us for
not transferring raw material
and reserving it for domestic use that
policy has also been revised
it's also important to note that the
indian government does not admit
to a shortage of production capacity
when states have said we do not have
enough vaccines
the national government has said you
actually do so there is also a problem
of the lack of acknowledgement of the
problem at hand
it's a very difficult situation indeed
in india dw's correspondent
misha jaiswal thank you so much for your
reporting